I am a broken man I don't know why but I
decided one day yesterday that I was
going to try to get a hundred thousand
steps in a single day I don't know if
it's because I'm in lockdown because of
coronavirus I don't know if it's because
I'm going crazy but I decided to do this
challenge and let me tell you I was
woefully unprepared for the amount of
work that would be required to
accomplish it and the insanity of what I
was trying to do in the first place the
average person in a given day if they're
even moderately active will walk 10,000
steps that's pretty impressive that's a
lot of steps I was doing ten times that
number I started my day off to see if I
could I was walking around my pool I was
experimenting I was seeing which style
of walking might do this because
theoretically in my mind I thought that
it would be possible I'm technically yes
it is possible however what I quickly
realized a hundred thousand steps is a
lot of steps there are only 86,400
seconds in a day of those 86,400 you're
only awake for about two-thirds of them
that gives you fifty seven thousand 24
seconds of rise and shine waking energy
to be able to do the walking that's
almost two steps a second for the entire
time that you're awake
you have to be walking at a vigorous
pace of about a hundred and thirty steps
per second or jogging at a hundred and
forty or in my case fast so after I
finished my initial research I started
to realize that I need to do adapt my
lifestyle to the mobile lifestyle I
literally can't stop stepping like it
doesn't matter like if I'm doing fast or
slow I think that's the only way that
I'm gonna be able to get to a hundred
thousand steps this seems like a bigger
task than I thought it was gonna be
always adding in steps wherever I could
no matter what I was doing I was always
moving and this is where the
psychological changes started to take
place I realized that my life was very
static I'm sitting down right now number
one I'm sitting down right now because
my legs don't work but number two I'm
sitting down just because that's what
normal people do at a computer I've got
a standing desk and sometimes I stand
depending on my mood or what type of
video I'm filming but for the most part
I live a pretty sentient Airy life so I
needed to change that that's gonna be a
doozy I need every excuse to walk today
that I can get so I started doing
everything mobile I made my coffee while
walking around I made my breakfast while
walking around and in doing so I got a
lot more clumsy than I was before I
ended up spilling things that ended up
spilling the pancakemix way more messes
than I ever thought I needed to I just
dropped trash on G but I was mobile and
I was getting my steps in and I hit
10,000 steps pretty early on in the day
which made me think hey maybe I've got a
shot at this the only problem is the
sheer scope of a hundred thousand steps
is it's a lie I actually noticed that I
was a lot more productive because I was
moving I had to use every excuse
possible to do something to move so I
ended up doing dishes I ended up
vacuuming that's a very mobile chore I
ended up doing the laundry which isn't
too mobile but it it is if you do it
inefficiently if you put away clothes
one at a time yeah it becomes a lot more
a lot more walking involved I did
everything
any spare moment of my time was
dedicated to walking because that's what
I had to do another challenge was just
Ronit walk while I was eating hot sauce
all over that shirt no no I'm a genius
what I didn't factor in was just the
sheer amount of calories I was gonna
burn doing this energy energy energy
walking takes energy and you don't think
of it very much because it's just
walking it doesn't feel like a lot of
work but when you're doing it all day
long you are burning an astronomical
amount of calories the average person
about 160 pounds will burn 40 calories
per thousand steps that's point zero
four calories per step now I'm a hundred
and eighty something pounds so a hundred
and eighty pounds would probably burn
around forty five per thousand steps so
divided by a thousand you get point zero
four five calories per step I'm trying
to do one hundred thousand I was gonna
burn four thousand five hundred calories
in a day if I did this and that's
assuming I'm not walking fast and I was
walking fast I had to do it fast I had
to do it fast because I didn't have time
it's Oh stab stab stab stab stab stab
stab stab step step step step step step
step step step step step step step step
step step step step step step step
try saying the words step a hundred
thousand times that's about the same I
ended up taking the dogs out walk down
to the park perfect excuse the dogs out
for a walk get their steps in get my
steps in dogs have it easy they have
four legs like they're taking twice as
many steps as I am cuz I got twice as
many legs it's not fair once I got about
two thirty one thousand steps I really
thought that I could do this and then I
had videos to make I had to figure out a
way to step while I was standing at my
desk I came up with a solution turns out
this watch doesn't really care if it's
on your wrist or on your ankle and if
I'm standing I can always march in place
and get my steps in that way I can still
play doom and workout let's do this work
around except for the fact that it's
like patting your head and rubbing your
tummy if you're trying to actually play
say doom eternal and you have to do the
hand-eye coordination thing and try to
step at the same time it's kind of hard
what I got my recording done I got what
I needed to do done
the rain started unfortunately it's
raining which means that I can't lap
around the pool and I am way off target
it's currently 4:18 and I'm at 42,000
steps like I'm not even halfway there
and it's four o'clock I gotta kick this
into overdrive but I got to figure out
how I was looking forward to walking
around the pool and walk inside traffic
inside so I kept trying to stay helpful
trying to help Amy around the kitchen
like your water tried to get in the way
of Amy playing animal crossing by
walking to try the TV great everything
was great then my watch started running
out of batteries 50 1986 miles I'm
officially half way there but there's a
problem
I've almost run my watch out of
batteries I have never in my life run
this thing out of batteries in a given
day this almost always lasts the whole
day
then came the trouble of trying to keep
track of my steps without my watch how
to download a pedometer then more
walking or walking or walking more
walking or walking walking walking
walking walking walking walking walking
walking
walk walk walk walk I was so god damn
hungry I'm starting to get hungry again
I was so unbelievably hungry ah feel the
hunger I couldn't fathom it at this
point in the day I had already eaten
about 3000 calories
I can eat 3000 calories in the day but
at this point food was just becoming a
chore so I take a dinner break
I start getting so hungry I'm getting
real tired my feet are hurting real bad
and I had a lot more walking left to do
it's 6:42
I've only got so many hours left in the
day to get 42 thousand steps so I walked
about sixty thousand steps in my foot
started hurting I'm getting this foot
pain like a deep pain in my biggest of
toes and I didn't know if my tiny
Tootsie's would be able to tolerate
another forty thousand steps but step I
did I had to adopt a quicker step salad
that was more like a jog and I I just
can't I can't describe the boredom look
at this book that been walking so long I
was just bored you know I and Amy who
was playing animal crossing that was fun
to watch but you know only for a little
bit the rest of the time it was just
like ow my foot all my legs all my
muscles god I'm hungry
that was it I was bored I was hungry and
I was in pain I've never had my life
boiled down to such simple needs my
heart rate was a consistent 100 to 110
for pretty much the whole damn day like
that's not a big workout but all day all
day my poor heart and then I made the
horrible mistake when I got to 70
thousand steps I decided I needed to
take a break so I laid down and what's
funny is the body has methods of
convincing you that you're stupider than
you try to become and when you do
something stupid enough your body
decides that it's time for the stupid to
go away and it shuts you down mid stupid
as soon as I lay down my legs literally
stopped working my legs
work and my muscles just wouldn't muscle
I physically can't I was like I'm gonna
take 30 and I'll see how I feel I don't
feel anything
oh my foot was in such pain I couldn't
jump couldn't do it couldn't do it to
save my life so painful Amy had made
cookies and I was just like I'll just
get a cookie I couldn't walk up the two
steps to get to the kitchen to get a
cookie I couldn't walk two steps game
over guys good good good try it Fair
Play no handshakes man just pure release
you know yeah I would have been laying
there in pain but all I could think
about when I was laying on the couch
eating a cookie was just my god thank
goodness I didn't want to hurt myself
trying to do this I'm not that big of a
dum-dum and when I got to the point
where I decided like okay I need to stop
for the sake of my own health I was so
happy I'd never been happier like I was
laying on the couch watching Amy play
Animal Crossing this is fantastic as
eating cookies like this is great I love
it life's good you know no problems at
all I love it but yeah I did that I mean
I didn't accomplish my goal but I got
damn close and I got a lot farther than
I thought I would that was the most
productive day I've ever had I got so
much cleaning done I got so much laundry
done so many chores around the house so
many little things that I thought like I
would never have time for and I did it
and I went and recorded videos too and I
walked seventy thousand steps and
probably more because my my watch wasn't
exactly super accurate at getting steps
I was like calculating out I was like
counting in my head a hundred and my
watch would record like 94 it's not
enough to get me to a hundred thousand
by any especially the imagination but I
think I actually got closer to
seventy-five thousand that day but even
so holy crap that was rough it was a lot
of work and the moral of the story is
that you know sometimes you're just
gonna try sometimes you just got to try
something stupid you know that no one
else will do just because you know
why not I'm gonna kill me might break my
foot but I love challenges like that I
love challenges that I don't know if I
can accomplish where literally I'm like
I have to dedicate myself to this 100%
otherwise it's just one of those
thoughts in your head that's gonna go in
and then pop out and never come to life
and that's so many ideas in my mind I
have tons of ideas of stuff that I
wanted to do all the time and I always
talk myself out of it because I think
it's crazy before actually doing and
this is just one of those things that I
didn't let sit in my mind and I didn't
let it become nothing I actually did it
I blow I mean I didn't I couldn't but I
tried and my only regret was that I
didn't stop at 69 thousand four hundred
twenty steps or did I two three four
come on please look like this it will
not move this is so weird
this thing will not move Thanks
Oh No
no-no-no